Hey, what's going on? Why
you're just checking in on you.
I can't go up that.
Hi everybody.
I am 10 shows in to my epic 19 show
run at the Wilbur Theater in Boston,
Massachusetts. And I got to tell
you, I'm a little bit, I got 10 down,
nine to go and I gotta tell
you this was a stupid idea.
Should have played a
venue a little bigger. Um,
all the shows have been going great.
Um, but I've been doing all right.
I've been taking a steam every
fucking day. Little Eucalyptus spray.
I'll be able to tough my way
through this shit, man. Um,
that's the extent of how difficult
my job is. I think my voice was,
I think my instrument will hold up.
You know,
you have all your other people doing the
fucking back breaking jobs right now.
You're not how many backbreaking jobs
or even left in this country, isn't it?
All infrastructure other than ups.
People will unload or load and unload ups,
trucks, construction. What
else is a difficult job?
Uh,
early on in your relationship and your
girlfriend as a fucking birthday coming
up? That's a difficult job, dude. What
do I get? Or, you know what I mean?
It's like I don't love it, but
I still want to fuck her. Right?
What kind of gift is that, dude?
You know, what should I do?
Should I get her a blouse?
Should I take it as a
box gift certificate?
Uh, my accent's going to be coming
back really strong. Jesus Christ,
I met this guy last night in so
many people think the Boston accent.
It's just that practicality in the habit.
Yet they met,
they miss all the law part of it.
This fucking game. Gramar George,
you've got to do your job.
Draw up Jay Jay,
WB guys comes walking.
You need,
he's not doing his fucking job
job. There it is. I can job job,
you know?
So anyways,
I got to tell you,
you know,
I was fucking rag in the last two podcasts
about Tom Brady and I gotta be honest,
man.
What a difference a couple of days makes.
This is all gradually just going
to blow over with real sports fans.
People who just straight up
hate the patriots will fucking,
now they're saying Aaron Rodgers
likes his ball a little over inflated.
Minnesota heats up the
footballs and Tom Brady,
let's a little bit out the end of the day.
You still gotta throw
the fucking thing right?
It's fucking idiot saying he's cheating.
Is that all you have to do to
make it in the NFL is a little,
a little bit of air out and
all of a sudden the ball
goes exactly where you want
it to be. It's so fucking dumb. But I'm,
I'm looking for the Patriots to, um,
you know,
Brady's already hired a lawyer.
They're going to go at this fucking
thing. I think we're sick of uh, uh,
the teams in the League fucking doing
all this country shit too is trying to
make it look like we're a bunch
of cheaters when we're not.
We're just kicking your fucking
asses and why don't you grow up?
Why don't you take your fucking skirt
off and just play the fucking game and
quit looking under every
goddamned jock strap.
Cause we can do the same thing to you
or write you a bunch of pussies. Sorry,
I'm really just talking about the jets.
I'm talking about the cults and I'm
talking about every other sports park
content out there.
I love to how everybody acts.
Like they've never been guilty of any
sort of gamesmanship looking for a fucking
edge.
Right.
You're never took a test and kind of
glanced over at the smart chicks fucking
paper over there. Right.
A little gamesmanship.
Okay.
Um, whatever. Uh, I'm
actually in a great sport,
smooth at this point because I've
realized at this point that, uh,
I think good Dale,
after all,
he went through last year with the ray
rice thing I'm with under suspending
somebody now. He's like a fucking
like a baby poisonous snake.
Just unleashing all the venom when he
doesn't need to do that, you know? Um,
I guess it's within every team's right.
If they want to fucking, I mean, I dunno,
I look at it like when they said George
Brett had too much fucking pine tar on
his bat.
Oh really?
Is that why you hit the fucking
home run to win the game really?
Because he had too much, too much sticky
stuff, so he got a better grip on it.
That little bit of extra sticky stuff,
you know,
if you never hit a home run
and a major league ballpark,
I don't know if you know this,
all you have to do is put a little pine
tar a little bit beyond the label on the
bat and you'll be, the thing's going to
be jumping right off the bat. It's crazy,
man. I don't know why McGuire
and those guys, you know,
poisoned their bodies
with all the steroids.
All they needed was just a little bit
of sticky stuff on that bat and then
forget it.
So anyways,
in other sporting news,
all Canadians,
you fucking lost again. I'm just giving
I, I would, I shouldn't be rubbing in it.
What the fuck am I to say?
My team didn't even make the playoffs,
but our congratulations to the Tampa Bay
lightning and Canadian fans as much as
I give you shit. Fuck it. I'm not, I,
you know, I want it. Am I going to do?
You guys got fucking 97 cups. You
know, granted both of them were one.
When your team was the team
plane was like a biplane.
You don't know or understand
about Canadian fans.
I always give you shit about how long ago
you won the cup and there was only six
teams in the league. Why don't you
guys ever say back to me? Yeah.
And the Bruins for one of them.
So why didn't you guys win 20 cups?
A bunch of people in French
just said, we exactly. Um,
let's see here. So I am, um,
10 shows in 10 shows.
And by the way,
the curse of Patrick Wall continues
the solemn saying, tell him saying,
and now I've got to congratulate
New York City. Well,
congratulations to the
New York fucking ranges.
I actually hate to admit this, but I
actually, I actually liked the ranges, um,
because I remember when they want it,
94 that uses like this. That's to me,
that was the greatest year in hockey ever
saw. Um, Mark [inaudible] we will win,
you know, breaking a fucking
50 [inaudible] 54 year curse.
I'm an original six team. It
was great, man. It was awesome.
And also at that point, the red sox
hadn't won the world series yet.
So I remember watching that going like,
wow,
maybe that's what that's gonna feel
like when we finally beat a beat,
somebody to win a world
series. So, um, God dammit,
Washington capitol fans. I mean,
what did you do? You know, you know,
we'd be a great fucking sports show
if you had like Washington capitols and
like San Diego charger fans sit down,
right? And just talking about all the
shit that they've been through. Right.
And then in the end,
you know, Jason Law had,
comes in crying worse than
anybody as a Cleveland Fan. Um,
and then a cubs fan walks in with
his horn rimmed glasses asking why?
Asking why anybody really gives a fuck.
As long as you take your shirt off and
have a good time, who cares? Right?
Who gives a fuck? Fucking red sox won. Oh,
I'm back in p town. I'm cage. People end
up with the sports. They're red sox one,
two to nothing. It gets, the
A's actually won the series.
I fucking miss it back here man.
I really do.
Sitting there talking to
my wife about it going,
what the fuck are we living out there?
And a God damn state that has no water.
You know what I mean? Coming back
here, lush land, bunch of trees,
lakes, you know, I
really miss my home town.
I fucking love it back here and I'm trying
to see like what I go fucking nuts if
I moved back here. I mean kind of be
difficult to still be in this business,
you know, to get acting work. We're not
be based here, but uh, I don't know.
I got to admit,
I got to admit it turned me on little
good fellas reference for you there.
Um, so anyways, uh, I got
to try to conserve my voice.
I don't even know what the
fuck I'm going to talk about.
This is how out of it I am.
Last night it came home.
I fucking come home late at night as
always. Oh, me and Rosie one night.
Jesus Christ. Jesus Christ. Dude,
we fucking stayed out till
like five in the morning.
I was driving home and the sun was
coming up, was sitting here like,
what am I doing? We ended up, uh,
we finished our shows and then these
guys will say saying, Hey, you know,
you got to come to our dive bar, a dive
bar around the corner. And we're like,
Whoa, we got a couple of cigars. I know, I
know. I said I was quitting, but whatever.
Um, we've got a couple of cigars and I
wanted to fucking needed a place where we
could smoke them, right? So he goes, yeah,
yeah, you know, come on over, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah. I'll probably get this
guarantee. I don't want to get this.
Get in trouble. And then we went
outside and we smoked him in the alley.
I want to thank everybody at a bitty
earlies flatten a smoke legally outside in
the alley. It's not even an alley.
They were outside on the sidewalk.
So when he was be fucking
ended up going there and um,
these guys,
fucking hilarious guys is off duty.
Cop is off duty firemen and they just
walked. They were already, you know,
fucking four hours into drinking at least,
you know,
and we just come walking in stone sober
and I had me and [inaudible] a little
hammered,
then we would've started telling stories,
but instead we just listened to the show.
And,
uh,
this fucking guy, man, I swear
to God, he's telling this
story and he's going like,
all right, you're not going to. But he's
like, fucking like leaning in on us.
He's gone. You know, I got fucking,
I got fucking two kids, right? I gotta,
I got a son and a daughter by two
different women. I know. I'm fucked up.
My life is fucked. I know.
So anyways, my daughter,
she's like fucking 10 years old and she
starts asking me about the birds and the
bees. I'm like, what the fuck? I
mean, I don't even know what to say.
So I just start, I, I freak out. So I,
I emailed my ex wife,
you know,
cause I can't call her because
of the restraining order.
And then he makes this face that looks
up in the air, like whatever that is.
And then he fucking goes,
I fucking end up telling,
I don't even know what I said to
her. I was like, you know a man,
a man's penis gets erect in it,
goes inside and it fertilizes I dude,
I fucking blacked out.
I came to like fucking 20 minutes later
and she's staring at me and my daughter
and then my new girlfriend's looking at
me like, dude, what the fuck did you say?
I mean, I see what, what am I supposed
to fucking, next thing you know,
he's talking about the marathon bombers
and how he was one of the guys that had
the rifle on the dude in
the boat and he's gone.
I got the FBI over here.
The fucking CIA is behind me.
I got my gun on his fucking
dude, right? I got it on him.
The FBI is in the other room,
fucking dude.
He started the story like 15 times
to the point. I finally go, Hey,
what side is the FBI on?
And he doesn't miss it.
Be the FBI is in the other room is
CIA is behind me. It's like, dude,
just get to it. And then the fucking
fireman guy goes and Yada, Yada Yada.
You didn't fucking shoot
them your bunch of pussies.
So those of you haven't been keeping
up on the, um, on the whole, uh,
that whole story there with
the Boston marathon bomber,
like he's on trial right now and uh,
I'm listening on the radio was listening
to one of those NPR things in there
talking about how, uh, you know,
the big question is, you know,
when they convict this guy,
does he get life in prison or the
Dia fucking kill them and you know,
I think it's a no brainer.
You take them out,
okay,
his life has already over,
what are you going to deal with?
Just stick them in a cage.
Okay.
It's over. You know what I mean? They're
trying to pull that shit. You know,
he was really influenced by
his brother. Yeah. You know,
I was influenced by my older brother, but
you know, if the second he starts going,
hey,
let's stick a fucking bomb in a mailbox.
Okay
next to innocent people, children,
you know, at that point I'm like, hey,
all the brother, you know, I think
you kind of going down a road.
I don't want to be on it.
MMM.
I Dunno. Yeah, I think you put them,
you put them down and he put them down
like a rabid dog. Am I out of my mind?
I like when they go like we don't come
from a country that's an eye for an eye.
They'll fuck. We don't what fucking
history book are you reading?
What apple when they scalped a couple of
us. Jesus Christ, we committed genocide.
Can't take our one fucking
bomber. Come on. All right,
this has been conservative bill
coming at you here on the podcast.
Um, so anyways, for those of you
guys who are new to this podcast,
I do this podcast every fucking Thursday
ride where people just, you know,
I just check in on you. That's all. I
see how your week's going. You know,
I worry about you guys.
I worry about you guys just got my
head busted at this fucking place.
I haven't gone to since I was a kid.
You know, we just call it the hack shop.
I'm not going to say the name of it,
but that's what we used to call it.
It's fucking guy go in there.
He's like fucking, you know,
there's the guy that's kind of old and
then there's the guy that's really old.
So I'm going, you know, and they're both
finishing a haircut. So I'm like, come on.
Almost old. Come on kind of. Oh,
maybe really old won't gave him an,
of course really old finishes
first we get there, right.
He's fucking funny as hell.
And I could just tell the
whole fucking thing's uneven.
So I had to try to fix it when I got
home, you know what I mean? And he goes,
we can, we need to say, hey, it got to
give the state troopers. Um, all right.
So anyways, um, let's get to the, uh,
the hashtags here.
Shit that you guys want me to talk about.
I got home so late last night.
I actually looked for some reason you
don't want just an old news stories pops
in. I started looking, I remember
Shondra is Shandra Levy, remember that?
And there was that politician and they
were about ready to fucking maybe make a
case on them. And then nine 11 happened.
He never fucking heard about it again.
I always wondered about that.
Okay.
The Thursday afternoon,
m m p for those,
uh, you people, you people that
want to fucking email in. It's uh,
for Thursdays it's a Hashtag
t a m. M. P. All right.
I know this one sucks so far. I'm going
to try to turn it around here. All right.
Aye. You got to talk
about dad bods. Oh yeah.
That was Michael Rappaport.
I am Rapaport podcasts where
he's talking about dead bodies.
I'm not a dad and I already have
that body. That fucking kills me.
It really kills me.
Um,
isn't an awful how in shape you can look
in with the shirt on fucking unreal.
Every time I'm thinking I'm
looking. All right. You know,
you catch that sideways
view of you in the marriage.
It's a fucking absolute shit show.
It's so fucking depressing.
Um, anyways, report show the
NFL may listen to podcast.
Brady suspension could be overturned.
It better be overturned. You know what?
I think all patriots fans should do,
every Patriot fan should go watch that
fed fucking documentary on Scientology
and rather than judging Scientology,
you know, he should really,
we'll look at it and be like,
well,
you could really make that documentary
about any religion, every religion,
if the core is a giant fucking guests.
Right.
But the greatest thing about getting
clear is Scientology wanted to be
recognized as a religion and then get
that tax break. And the IRS is like, no,
you guys are a cult gimme a break. You
know, you're talking about space ships.
We don't believe in that stuff, so fuck
you guys. And they basically sued them.
They had like 2,500 2,700 of their members
individually filed a lawsuit against
the IRS.
Never been defeated.
The fucking Mayweather,
right. The Rocky Marciano of,
uh, I, I don't even think they are a
government agency, are they? Aren't.
They worked for the Federal Reserve,
which is a private group of people
that don't, that print the money.
I don't fucking know. All I know
is the shit I over here and buys.
So they defeated them.
2,700 individual lawsuits from one
group defeated the fucking IRS.
So they go,
I say,
if they don't overturn this
fucking Tom Brady suspension,
I am going to fucking rally every
Patriot fan I know to sue the NFL.
Alright, for emotional damage
done for you guys. Lion, our bod,
our quarterback who looks like
a fucking astronaut. Okay,
we'll fucking smell fucking show you when.
That'd be great.
Just fucking overturn it.
Then we'd be called a bunch
of cry and whine and assholes.
But who gives a fuck that do fun.
Gay coming to work today.
Don't talking to my lawyer about my
fucking lawsuit against the fucking NFL.
Um, I really think we ought to do
that fucking child. This one is one.
I'm still waiting for the day that the
light is gradually going to shine on a
gym or say somebody at some point.
Can you look under one fucking rock
and just take a look at that guy?
I'll give you a hint. He sits on the
competition committee. Start with that.
Just start with that. And Ben, you just
look what happened when he sat there.
What his team looked like,
what his team's strengths were,
and what were some of the new rules
that got implemented. I know, I know.
I'm fucking going crazy.
I should be standing here with a fucking
legal pad next to a fireplace doing
stand up in front of three people.
Um, all right. Uh, let's see,
what else do we got?
Yeah,
what do we got here? What if it's
California against Florida for the cup?
Your thoughts? Oh my God, I
didn't even think about that.
What if it's Anaheim
first fucking Tampa Bay.
Okay.
Ooh, just picturing that is really
cheesy. I would still watch. So,
cause there are great
teams, you know, something,
you know what gives 'em that really
gives Tampa Bay credit I think is Steve
[inaudible],
you know what I mean?
He's such a hockey guy is
such an ambassador for the
sport and I just think what
he's doing down there, it was great.
And uh, I have to be honest with you,
I love the lightning and I
also love the devil rays.
And I think I don't like about the
devil rays. Is it just called the race?
You know, I mean, I don't get why people
down there and Clearwater and Tampa.
I don't get what you're afraid of. I
bend down there. I've seen the people.
All right. The devil is
all over Tampa. Okay.
I don't think it's going to
influence anybody one way or
the other, um, with, okay,
if it was Tampa versus,
um, the ducks, you know,
I really liked both of those teams. I
gotta be honest with you. I like, uh,
I kinda like what's his face there?
The form of capital's coach.
Cause everybody was kind
of like, Eh, you know,
okay.
He doesn't have what it takes to get
them over the hump. I think either way,
it'd be a great story. And I also
love Ironman. So, uh, you know what,
I would, I would root for a seven
game series of that happened. But, uh,
the other option would be
Chicago verse the Rangers. Um,
I dunno, range has got a shot, man. They
got a shot. It definitely got a shot.
But,
um,
I think most people are saying whether
it be wins between the ducks and the
Blackhawks, but, you know, something,
I've missed all of this shit cause I've
been doing two shows every night down at
the Wilbur and I want to thank
everybody who's, uh, who's been going,
coming out to the show is me.
It's been fucking ridiculous.
I'm doing a late show on a Monday
night, Tuesday night, Wednesday night.
Just the fact that people even
coming out to the early show.
So I'm blown away by the support out
here. So I hope you guys have been on, um,
enjoying the shows and it's certainly
having a good time performance for you
other than my voice being
a little fucked up. Um,
okay. Bill, do you have any
radio shows slash other podcasts,
not Diversey effect that you already
mentioned that, uh, you would recommend,
um,
that you guys don't know about?
Okay.
I mean, the shit, I like
the opiod Jimmy show. Um,
I always liked Howard Stern fucking,
um,
the other guys.
I was like the other guys in Atlanta,
mmm.
That she can actually, but listen to
online. This is a whole new game here.
Actually, Joe Rogan, you guys probably
already, if you listen to my podcast,
you know about Rogen and Marin
and all those guys. Yeah.
MMM.
You know what was a fault of my,
one of my favorite radio shows of all
time was to fill Henry Cho and he used to
do this thing where it was this amazing
thing where he would host the show,
he would bring up a topic and then
he would have a caller call in,
but the color was actually him and his
collar would just say the most craziest
shit and it would just get
other callers to call in.
He was like the original troll.
And then the other people would call in
and argue with this phantom color that
was actually fill Henry.
And then he would, uh,
and then he would moderate
it the same time I,
and he's actually doing a voice on
f is for family. And I finally got,
I was so such a thrill to talk to him.
I asked him how he did it and he just
said he was clicking off from one
microphone to the other and every once
in a while somebody would figure it out
and call a B, you know, is this the same
guy? And then you quickly hang up on them.
And some of the classic
ones at this point,
I think he can just listen to them online.
But he had one where he was talking
and was like this, like the 20th,
the 25th anniversary of
the Star Wars trilogy.
And he called in and you know,
called in his own show basically,
and he was pretending to be some big
star was fed. And he was going like,
and he was like, yeah
man. He's going like, uh,
in empire strikes back was awesome.
And I loved that po where we're
the with Darth Vader is Luke,
I'm your father, you bitch
and blah, blah, blah, blah.
And he just kept going back to that quote,
go on Luke, I'm your father, you bitch,
and blah, blah, blah. And Phil would
then as a host, go, yes, I remember that.
That was, that was an incredible, uh,
of credible twists in that trilogy.
I would think that all star wars fans,
uh,
we'll put that rank that in the top three
and the guys on. Yeah, man. He said, um,
you find that you bitch and then
somebody calls in, he's gone. Ah, yeah.
I just wanted to talk to the collar.
Yeah. He just says, Luke, I'm your father.
He doesn't say, Luke, I'm
your father. You Bitch. And he
just kept saying, yeah, yeah,
Luke, I'm your father. You Bitch. And the
people would sit there and argue with it,
wouldn't figure it out.
He pretended to be pilots talking
about seeing goblins on his, uh,
on his wings one time and some
real pilot calls and go and look,
I don't know who this guy flies forward,
but there's no way he saying that he
reported that to any sort of FAA agency or
he would be grounded immediately.
And then Phil just goes,
are you calling me a liar?
And then we'll just immediately
launch into this argument.
It was fucking tremendous.
Um, I dunno. Other than that,
you know, I'm an old guy and all the radio
shows I like to have gone off the air.
I was actually flipping through
the Boston stations here,
like what had happened to
BC and I couldn't find Waf.
Wh J why it's all gone.
It's got,
um, anybody else remember
that? The big mattress show.
Uh, all right, where are we going?
Oh, hey Billy drumming. Drumma boy.
What you know about Jimmy,
Jimmy Chamberlain, uh,
that's the guy from smashing
pumpkins. Um, I believe, right?
Not as much as I should
know. Does that, uh,
does that count a look at that?
Somebody made a new logo for the colts.
It's a blue and white pass a fire
right on the side of the fucking,
and it's Saturday omelette.
I love it. Please.
More of that. I would really
enjoy it. All right, so, uh,
let me read a little bit of advertising
here. Uh, for this week's podcast.
Dude, I am so fucking wiped
out. This was, you know,
this was such an amazing thing to
do to be able to do these shows.
And within three shows. I was like,
this is a really dumb idea. Um,
oh my God. Fucking voice.
All right, Uber, Hey,
oh fuck. This is part, this is, I thought
this was a question Uber. Everybody. Hey,
you like making great money,
right?
Here's a really cool opportunity that I
had to share with you driving with Uber.
Uber's that populous smartphone APP
that connects riders with drivers.
Um, my wife takes Uber all the time, um,
you know, when she seems to have a
good time with it. Um, and in chatting,
okay, I'm supposed to be saying
that I take it, well, I do take it,
I take it with my wife and every
dental guy loved them by the way.
And in chatting with different drivers,
some of them have really interesting
stories as to why they drive with Uber.
You know, what I do love about Uber
is it's a nice clean fucking car.
I will tell you that.
And I've yet to get in there with
somebody who smells like they just fucking
played a game. Seven. How about that?
Is that enough as a of a
personal endorsement for you? Um,
the people who drive love being their
own boss, they earn great money.
It's easy to start.
You just need a car and a license.
Do this really is a fucking
unbelievable employment opportunity.
Like back in the day when you
got laid off, he was screwed.
How do I make my car payment?
You can just call Uber and now you
were employed driving around a bunch of
people. That's your arm out the
window. You're your own boss.
I don't need to read the rest of us.
This is a fucking no brainer work.
When you want to work, get paid in
cash. I think you do anyways, uh,
driving with no you don't. It's
a credit card. Fucking IRS. Uh,
driving with Uber is great for anyone
who needs flexibility. Parents,
this is a really, really easy way to work
around your family schedule. Students.
You can make some extra money between
classes now as the prime time to cash in
with driving Uber. Uh, you'll thank me for
telling you how to get paid every week.
Uh,
I could be getting you into a car when I
could be getting into your car when you
drive with Uber and it would be weird.
Uh,
any big podcast listeners this
way you live, um, you got to go.
He got a car and a license.
Put them both to work and start earning
serious money. Life changing money today.
Sign up to drive with Uber.
Visit drive with uber.com. Uh,
that's drive with Uber,
you U B e R. Dot Com.
Um, I'll do it. If I was a young man,
if I had the fucking time I would do that
shit. I would definitely do that shit.
Beat stuff. Fuck gotta go into
one office, doesn't it? Um,
Bombus chances are if you have feet,
you wear socks. Everyone. And face it.
Socks haven't changed since they
were invented that we did not.
What ends up happening and they fall down.
They were out and there was always the
toe seem that never seems to be in the
right place. You know what
happens? You Soc, Sag,
you bowl sag and then you
accept that weak fucking raise.
Your boss is trying to give you.
You know what I mean?
It's a metaphor you want you, if you
want your sock standing up straight,
just like you, Dick, our new
sponsors, Bombus has changed.
All of that bomb was,
is dedicated.
They actually make a sock for your Dick
too when it stands up straight. Okay?
You got to how much she can fill it up.
And if you fill it up
beyond the fucking heel,
they give you a free pair of thongs.
A bombers is dedicated to two years to
engineer socks that stay up last forever
and feel amazing on your feet.
Um,
they actually sent me a pair
of bomb as they feel great.
There's nothing better than new
socks. Puts you in a good mood, right?
Your wife could suggest
something horrific. Hey,
let's have a picnic. You know,
you got on a new pair of socks. You're
like, you know what? That sounds awesome.
I really think that my feet
feels so good right now.
I could actually tune you out
on the side of a hill. Uh,
there's so comfortable the honeycombs
stitching, it just hugs your foot.
You know these socks care mayor,
these socks care more than your mother.
Um, so whether you're walking or
running, you feet feel perfect.
I find myself washing them over
and over so I can wear them again.
I need to get more. Will you stop
fucking doing that with the copy?
I don't find I find myself washing them
when they're dirty. I enjoy the socks.
Isn't that enough? Jesus Christ. When,
when you guys led up to
know what I'm talking about,
you really need to try out a
pair for yourself. But listen,
Mama's doesn't stop with your
comfort with every pair of socks.
Bomba sells a pairs.
Donate to someone in need.
This is great right here because socks is,
it turns out are the number
one requested item, um,
at homeless shelters right now other
than drugs right now for a limited time
bomb has, is offering my listeners 20%
off their first order and free shipping.
Just go to [inaudible] dot
com slash [inaudible] all
lowercase Bombus is spelled
B o m.
B a.
S do it now for 20% off the most
comfortable socks and the planet.
And a pair for someone in need,
go to [inaudible] dot com slash
burr that's B o m B a s.com/bar.
All right, I'm going to start wrapping
up the podcast here. You don't,
one of the great things this week,
um,
aside from seeing a bunch of people
that I'd gone to high school with,
people who have been coming in and,
and you know,
I've been having them come backstage
and, uh, like I said, it's been awesome.
You know, I just been running into people
and everybody seems to be doing well.
Everybody's happy,
seem to be happily married.
Actually ran into one of my friends who
just got divorced within the last couple
of years and I got to tell you,
he was fucking ecstatic.
Is there anything better as a guy than
meeting another guy that's happily
fucking divorced? He's just,
fuck, he's loving life. You
know, he's got an apartment,
a couple, two, three boys, you
know, he's like, oh dude, it
was time. It's tea. He goes,
you know what I love about it best?
He goes,
he'll be sitting in my apartment
and there's a bar across the street.
And he goes, see, I just
think to myself, wow,
if I want to I can just
walk right over there.
I can walk right in there and get a
beer, you know, very simple thing.
So I know right there, a lot of
women are probably thinking like, oh,
this guy was a bad husband. He was out
there drinking all the time. You know,
there's always that fucking option.
But then there is the other option that,
you know, sometimes ladies, you know, you
hold onto the reigns a little too tight,
you know what I mean? He kinda Yank
and they head back and uh, you know,
it's that horse wants to run,
going to have,
you're gonna have some problems.
You know,
if you get some old mayor that's
going to go to the glue factory,
I'll let you fucking lead them
wherever the fuck he wants. You know,
you married a stud, right? You
got yourself $1 million horse day.
You got to let that thing run every
once in a while. There you go ladies.
And then go off to the pub and get a
fucking good buzz going every once in a
while. You know, I know you're
married. I know you got kids.
I know he comes home and he fucking
mistakes to sync for the toilet,
but every once in a while, you know,
maybe once a month, once a month.
You know what? I would be
fucking amazing. All right,
let's just say you were in a marriage
right now and you know your husband is a
little, a little miserable, you know,
and every once in a while he needs
to go out and be frank the tank.
What if you just let him get Uber,
right? You get him a pair of Bomba socks.
You get them an Uber and
say, you know what, honey?
Once every four to six weeks you can
go out with the fellas and just get
absolutely fucking loaded.
All right?
You come walking in through
the fucking cellar doors.
We'll have a couch down there.
You pass out the next morning,
the kids won't know shit.
All right? Just fucking,
just blow out the pipes and then fuck.
And then he can come home.
And then,
you know,
once every four to six weeks I get to
go do whatever it is that women do that
they consider fun. I have no idea what
you guys do. What is it that you guys do?
You know,
I know women fucking love women love a
glass of wine around four or five o'clock
uh oh that is this a Gar,
Huh guys? She wanted your fucking
wife to chill out. You know,
just fucking pour a glass every day around
five o'clock and she's bitch moaning
and complaining as you just go shoo blub,
blub, blub, blub, blub, blub, blub, blub.
Let it sit out right on the
back porch. Go ahead. You know,
she's in a really bad mood. Pour another
glass. She'll be asleep by six 30 right?
Then you go in with your kids.
What do you do?
You throw in the fucking talk in plain
movie with Dane. Cook is a voice,
right? Get Dane Cook a little
bit of scratch. Your kids
is staring there. You know,
you fucking poor a whiskey. That's,
that's what parenting is all about.
Working with your partner.
So that the two of you can get a good
buzz going every other day without the
kids noticing. And I know kids notice a
lot, but you stick them in front of a TV,
they got no idea what's going on right?
There you go. And you know something.
I think that that's one to grow on.
You guys ever watched those that I talk
about this. Did you guys ever watched,
I already talked about this and I don't
give a shit. You guys got to go look up.
Uh, uh, will forte's like
greatest hits on a, the SNL site.
Just go on and just search will
forte and he got to get those,
those ones where they do
that, uh, those whole, um,
Jesus bill spit it out where they do the
whole spoof on. That's one to grow on
with a gun. Uh, once their face there,
which she goes tapping and tapping and
tapping on my kibo gotta get that to my
bowels.
Huh?
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking
about anymore. All right. 10 shows down,
nine to go. Here's the thing,
when the next time I got,
next time I talked to you guys,
um,
will be on Monday and I'll have my
final two shows. Number 18. Number 19.
All right. Freddie Lynn, who's
a famous 19 Joe Thornton.
I'm trying to think in Boston sports.
Is that what he wore?
Okay,
Randy [inaudible], has there ever
been a great 19 and Boston sports?
Wasn't Fred Lynn 18 or was he 19?
Maybe?
[inaudible] was 18 and Freddie,
Freddie Lynn was 19. Uh, Fred Lynn.
Oh, what a fucking ball player
through the end of the day.
He was a California boy and
they ended up with the fucking,
ended up with the angels. All that
killed me. Do you know that was our, our,
our field.
We had Fred Lynn and center Santa
Dwight Evans, the greatest fucking,
um,
you have a saw and we had Jim rice
and we had butch Hobson at third.
Rick Bellson. It's short. Jerry
Remy, the ram dog. It's second.
We had George Scott at first,
Carlton Fisk behind the plate.
And we had Carl Yastrzemski at Dh.
We still didn't win a world series.
Fucking brutal. Absolutely fucking brutal.
So anyways, um, I think
that's it. That's the, uh,
the podcast for this week.
I know the energy's a little low here.
People just work with me here over
the next fucking podcast as I, uh,
I really gotta go easy here on the voice
because you know who's kidding, who?
I don't really know how to write a joke.
So I do a lot of silly faces screaming
the effort and I'm paying for it right
now. All right. Hey ladies,
once every six weeks, you know,
just let them go out and get fucked up.
You know,
dorm are solid and just say, listen,
I'm letting you get fucked up,
but you have to be fucking husband
of the year for a week. Is that cool?
It'd be site be fucking sites.
Right?
And all you guys got to do every once
in a while you pour a glass of wine and
then you've got,
and then you're good.
And then your kids grow up to be
raging alcoholics. And you know what?
A family that drinks together stays
together. All right, you guys have,
we, we can you have a great fucking
weekend? I'll talk to you later.
I want a girl with the mined diamond.
Have you guys seen this stuff about
the, uh, all the suicides at the, uh,
the apple plant. You know,
that really Canty commercial
where they go, uh, you know,
if you don't have an iPhone then
you don't have the iPhone, you know,
and I want it to get an iPhone until I
saw those God damn commercials and they
kept like, uh, just, it's most bizarre
advertising.
It makes me angry at the iPhone.
I've never had any anger towards the
iPhone or the people who had one.
I never gave a shit. I was
like that phones to shit.
I heard it. It drops calls.
I'll wait till it's on Verizon and then
right when it gets on Verizon and I'm
all ready to jump on board,
they come up with this Nananana
fucking country shit going. You know,
if you had an iPhone right now,
you could be looking at the inside
he your fucking throat and, uh,
diagnosing your fucking throat cancer
before it even happens. You know,
but if you don't have the iPhone,
you don't have the iPhone.
It's like well fuck you.
I'm Cuban sticking with the droid.
So anyways,
now I read they just had the 10th suicide
at the apple plant.
Now who's kid?
Until we all know that
everything that we're wearing,
everything that we're using is made by
some four year old making 6 cents an hour
somewhere. We'll evidently they,
these people have had enough.
They've had 10 suicides at
the apple plant. Here we go.
On the same day that apple,
Dell,
Hewlett Packard promised to look into
working conditions at China's Foxconn
plant,
a 10th worker committed suicide.
The death of a 19 year old male
male worker. Uh, it's too bad.
He was like one year away from getting
his fucking severance pay or is a shit.
I fucked it up. What the hell do you get
it when you do 20 years in the force?
Ah God, I'm sorry everybody.
I'm on my fucking vacation mode.
What the Hell I get my pension.
What does that,
when you worked 20 years on the force
and he's only 19 you get it.
Cause he's been working since
he was two. Oh Jesus. Um,
the death of a 19 year old male worker
also came just after the company's
billionaire founder took the media on
tour of the sprawling complex in response
to accusations from Labor groups that
workers toiled and sweat shop like
conditions. All hilarious. So
then the billionaires shows up,
they cleaned the place up, stick in a
water bubbler and goes, see, it's great.
Um, and I know what a lot of you
fucking heartless consequent to say.
You're going to say, well,
sweatshop labor is necessary.
Do you want to pay $8,000 for a
laptop? What? Here's my rebuttal.
You know what if the content,
the top didn't have to
make $1 billion a year?
You know, kind of like when they were
talking to the oil companies and they go,
you're projected to make 350 billion.
How about you just make 340 billion?
Do you have to make that much money?
That's the thing.
The people at the top are taken
way too much fucking money.
There's no fucking way that the only,
a reasonable way to make a laptop is
to give people such shitty wages that
suicide is a better fucking option.
And you do it at the fucking plant to
make some sort of political statement.
There's just no fucking way. How
about the people at the top? You mean
once you got $100 million to what?
What do,
do you ever need to get another paycheck?
I don't understand that.
And I'm not saying that the people
at the top shouldn't be filthy,
stinking rich because
they came up with it.
But you shouldn't be paying people. This
shouldn't be sweat shops, everybody.
That's all I'm saying.
And what sucks is that we actually came
up with unions in this country because
of sweatshop like conditions. And, uh,
but what ended up happening was the
people in the unions took advantage of it.
And with their strength,
they became a bunch of sloppy Douche
bags to the point that there's a lot of
people who actually have
negative views about unions.
That's how bad it is in this country.
And they're actually excited that
they're going to do away with unions.
A lot of people want to do away with
fucking unions rather than reformed them.
But to do away with them is we're going
to end up like these poor bastards and
in fucking China, you know, so and
shit together and go and you know what?
I think I'd rather jump out the fucking
window then make another God damn iPhone.
Um,
so anyways,
it says the company has
bought psychiatrist and
Buddhist monks to the factory,
to the factory complex to support workers
and now plans now play soothing music
along production lines. Why don't
you just fucking pay them? Um,
it plans to install 10 foot tall,
tall fences to stop workers jumping from
buildings and may give workers a 20%
pay raise. This is how tight
these fucking rich concer.
Let's play soothing music and
put a fence up. We'll try,
we'll try that first rather than just
giving them more money. What is it?
What is it 20% pay raise when
you make it 8 cents an hour? Um,
and anyways,
Foxconn representatives maintain that
the increase would not be in response to
the suicides, but it's being considered
because business has been good. Yeah.
Give me a fucking break.
Justice
my neighbor's ass.
Yes.
Generally speaking are we're going to go
with yes. A hey bill loved the podcast.
No. Yeah, that's east coast. Oh,
okay. Uh, that's why people bitch.
Where the fuck is a podcast?
I need some advice on what to do about
the got this guy lives in a few houses
down from me. I'm a third year
college student and I live at home.
My parents moved, uh, to go
live in the state above mine.
You mean north and I currently reside,
uh,
alone while they are
trying to sell the house.
A few months ago I was driving home,
coming back from a gym and while
I was driving in my neighborhood,
I saw this guy step in the middle of
the road, about 20 yards from my car.
He was yelling something at me,
but I couldn't hear what he was saying.
I slowed down to stop my car right in
front of him and he came to my window and
told me to get out. I was totally
confused and thought I'd run over.
I thought I ran over his cat or something.
Also,
I think he just moved in because
I'd never seen the dude in my life.
So I rolled down the window and ass.
Why did you say he goes,
I'm going to kick your fucking ass.
Get out of the car.
This guy's probably in his forties
and has to be around five 10 is that,
does this me? Um, 250 pounds.
That's not me. I'm 21, six, three,
200. I do crossfit and I wrestle
occasionally at another gym I go to.
So I got out of the car and I'm standing
there trying to figure out what the
hell is going on.
The guy starts moving towards me,
so I take the initiative
and take a step towards him.
We ended up being an inch from each other
and he's trying to do some alpha male
shit by just staring at me.
But I have the height advantage.
So I'm looking down at him at least
10 seconds go by before the guy goes.
How fast do you think you were going
back there? I say, I don't know,
probably around 30.
The speed limit in my neighborhood is 20,
and I know I wasn't going that
much over it. Then he goes,
I'm not going to have my children
playing in the yard if I no assholes,
like you drive in like that
and the neighborhood after, uh,
he said that I saw his wife and son were
a little off to the side of the road
once the word asshole left his miles,
I was fucking pissed.
I wanted to just tackle the Dick and put
him to sleep in front of his wife and
kid to teach them a lesson,
what I pussied out and just apologize
to them and said that I was really Solly
sorry.
And it wouldn't happen again.
The guy then gives me a fucking little
smirk and turns around and says while
walking away with his back turned it
better not or you know what will happen.
Ah, yeah, yeah.
He definitely should have kicked his
ass. He said, I kicked his ass. Yeah.
What the fuck do you do?
You realize what a good do
you realize what this kid did?
He's such a fucking gentleman.
He could've kicked the
fucking shit out of this guy.
He saw his wife and kid there. It
would have been emasculated. Yes.
Dad Is Superman. He sits there. You know
what it is? It's that little smirk. Yeah,
that fucking smart. I bet that con steals
from work. Yeah, I bet he does. Sorry do.
That's the first time I literally
had to walk away. You fucking cunt.
Yeah. He should have kicked
that guy's ass. But it's a good,
it's good that you didn't do it,
but because you weren't as
the bigger person as they say.
But he definitely has a comment.
Then he writes now after that, that
shit, I want it to explode. I mean,
the guy totally disrespected me,
so I get in my car and drive
off and his story wrong.
I couldn't get this fucking
guy out of my head. I do it.
I can't get it out of my head.
I'm going to actually fantasize
that I was there and he did that.
What I would want to do. I've already,
you know what I would fucking do?
I would wait till he was alone.
Don't do this shit. Don't do this.
But I know what you just want to get
up. Get the guy alone and be like, Hey,
what are you going to do now? Huh?
Huh? What are you going to do now?
You just get right in his fucking
grill and have him back down
or I, I would almost just say
we got to say, hey listen man,
just call them over the car and just say,
listen,
I just wanted you to know the other day
that if I wanted to I could have fucking
stuffed you in my trunk.
Tied you up like a fucking pressel and
ass rate you in front of your fucking
wife. But I chose not to. Okay.
Cause I didn't want your son to know
what a little fucking, I can't say it.
Pussy he has for that wouldn't
have been homophobic either.
I wouldn't mean me talking about gay
people. That's such a fucking pussy move.
Yeah. And if for some reason
but, but I'm putting no,
then that's what you say. Maybe do
it like Columbia to say, listen man,
I gotta ask you something because I'm
six foot three. I crossfit. I wrestle.
Okay. And just looking at you. I
know I could tie into a pretzel.
I know I could do it if I wanted to,
but the confidence you had,
I just want to know what is
your background. You know,
cause you know I'm a real competitive guy.
You know,
if you've got some sort of
martial arts training, you know,
I would love to have you once we didn't
she come down to the gym sometime when
your wife and kid aren't there.
So I don't have to feel guilty when I
fuck you up and close both your eyes with
this one and his friend over here.
What does the rest of the things say?
I don't even need to read it,
but it's not over though. I know.
Because this is what's happening now.
This is what happens when you do
the right thing in life. Okay.
When you know it, it eats away
at you. You have to make peace.
You have to make peace and eat and you
got to tell yourself the lie that someday
this guy's going to get his.
And you know what?
He doesn't guys like this don't get
theirs. Oh, that's smart. This kid,
this kid really painted a fucking picture.
I can. This is driving me nuts. He goes,
I couldn't get this guy to my head.
A week went by and I was still
thinking about that asshole too.
I would think about this guy. 20
years from now, two weeks later,
I was driving home from school and I see
the guy rolling is garbage can out to
the curb.
I slow down to fucking under 20 and I know
this because I looked down at my spit.
Tom's pedometer.
I pretend to stare the guy down.
So I look at him and he looks
at me and yell, slowed out.
Wow.
Now when he said that I am fucking raging,
I want it to stop my car and do some
ground and pound on his face. Yeah.
This kid knows what he's doing.
This isn't wrestling with
this kid's doing UFC shit,
but did I know I just drove off like a
fade the next day I talked to my friend
about it,
about what had happened and he said
that this guy said the same shit to him.
If he said it, he would have put
him on his ass. I know you do.
You know what I would've
done? He told me that, uh,
if he says he's going to kick your ass,
then that's a threat so you can defend
yourself. Listen to your dumb friend.
He's saying you won't get arrested.
So a few months have passed and I'm still
thinking about this asshole every time
I drive by his house.
Fast forward.
Okay.
Uh,
two yesterday and um,
okay,
I'm biking in my neighborhood.
Let's do an I hop I and I
hear a honk from behind me.
So I pull my bike over to the side of the
road and it's none other than the same
dude in his Ford F-150 driving along and
he looks at me and gives me the middle
fucking finger.
Wow.
Okay.
Now,
granted I was in the middle of the road
and didn't hear the guy coming because I
was listening to music, but still
the middle finger. So I bike home,
take a shower and try to convince myself
to walk over to the dude's house and
confront him.
But after a couple minutes of pacing,
I just decided to wait it out until the
asphalt does. One more thing. I mean,
I don't want to get arrested.
So my question is, what the
hell should I do? I mean,
every time I drive by this guy's house,
now I want to fucking veer off the road
and ran my car into the middle of his
living room. Any advice would be good. Uh,
all of my friends think I should go over
there, but I want a second opinion. Um,
uh, you can't do anything to this
guy unless he puts his hands on it,
unless he puts his hands on you.
This is just one of these things,
but you can do to him what he's
doing to you. This guy has an insane
temper.
So,
uh, you know, I'm not advocating
legally so you don't do this.
But like,
um,
I don't, I dunno what I
would next time, you know,
if you see him out in the yard or
something, this is what you do.
I have a great idea. Do you have any
friends who are really good mechanically?
Um,
why don't you take your credit card out,
go down to the fucking
auto store or whatever.
I'll go online and buy like one of
those fucking train horns and have it
installed in your car and next
time you drive down the street,
just be sort of zigzagging down the
street just to get this guy to be fucking,
you know, getting all like, oh, what the
fuck? And the second he starts screaming,
you lay on that fucking horn is loud as
humanly possible and you blow out his
ear drums. That's what I would, but then
again, then no one too. She liked us.
He would say that I have
permanent hearing damage.
You know what I think you should do?
Maybe because I'm a female and I'm
all about the cycle of bench. Okay.
Psychological warfare. What should he
do? I think when the husband is not home,
I don't know if he,
if he knows his schedule or whatever,
he needs to go over there when the
wife is at home and be like, listen,
you know I'm so sorry about that time
that I was speeding. I really, you know,
but your,
your husband's seems really upset.
I'm really not trying to be like that.
I would never do anything like that.
And women I, oh no, no, no, cause she
knows her husband is a psycho and like,
I mean she could turn it around and be
like, yeah, you shouldn't do that either.
But I have a feeling she's not like that
and he can just go over and just make
nice and be like the sweet
kid that's helping out or oh,
do you need me to take the mouse
out? And then, but then the,
I feel like maybe that would fuck with
the husband and he's like sitting there
sipping tea with the, the way
if it, oh look who came over.
He just wanted to apologize in person.
And you know,
I dunno. I Dunno. There's,
there's and then fuck the wife.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
He should fuck his wife.
Play with his kid in the backyard.
Like the toss the football around with
him and be more like, you know, like this.
You can't do it. There's
nothing like, just start
keeping them the finger. Listen,
this is a deal. All you gotta
do is just give him the finger,
give him the finger right back.
Cause uh,
this guy thinks you're a bitch right
now. So all you going to do is, you know,
you can just yell back. Just say,
you know, just give him the finger,
yell back at him when he's in the
driveway. I would like swerve,
add him and then swerve back.
Just fuck with the guy. He's not,
I mean just do that once because the
next time you might have like a video
camera, but um, uh, I,
I just don't want to get any,
you know what,
if I was in that situation a dude,
you know what I would dope. Yeah.
Oh Monday morning quarterback.
Look while I was in that situation
with that other guy, right? Yeah.
At the last place we lived and I didn't
fuck with him cause he was an old guy.
I just didn't fuck with them.
And how we found out he has dementia
and all this shit. So I'm site.
I never yelled at the guy,
you know what you do now.
You know what's what really diffuses
angry guys like that or it makes him even
more angry. It's just laugh at
them. Just keep laughing at him,
laugh at them, give him the finger
and just keep calling them. Tough guy.
Tough guy.
Anything do anything.
You just keep calling them anything that
is remotely. All right dad, Chuck Norris.
Anything you want to say to this guy
that will bait him into hitting you?
This is a really a fuck.
This is a great question and I don't
want to get in trouble if some shit goes
down so you shouldn't do
anything, sir. Wink, wink, wink.
Um, this guy's such a dick. I
know. I always say, you know,
fucking with somebody whose car was like
a pussy move with this guy such a dick.
And he has like such
a, uh, oh my God dude.
How many times you thought about throat
to just choke slam and that guy ran into
the hood of your car repeatedly as
his wife and son. It's in my trunk.
Vanji like a friend saw an ass rapey
nobody if you just said it really calmly,
if you set a comedy,
it was sort of a smile on your face.
You come off like a fucking
maniac. Yeah, that's true.
If you scream that at somebody,
you just sound like you're quoting like
Hulk Hogan or something. Right? Yeah.
Let me tell you something,
brother, come this Saturday,
I'm going to beg in the
proximal and past white team.